what I want to do in this video is think
about the different ways to make five so
what do I mean about that so right over
here we have three plus something so
there's some unknown number right over
here
three plus something is going to be
equal to five and in this diagram we
have three circles here that represents
the three and then we have five boxes
one two three four five and so how many
more circles do we need in order to fill
up all the five boxes we've clearly
already filled three well let's think
about it we just have to add one and two
circles now we have a total of five
three blue ones and two of this purple
color or that I guess this pink color so
we see that three plus two three plus
two is equal to five so that mystery
number here that blank is two three plus
two is equal to five now over here we
have two plus some mystery number is
equal to five again and once again we
have five spaces and two of them are
filled in with these kind of purple pink
stars so how many more do we have to
fill it in order to fill in all five
boxes two plus what is equal to five and
I encourage you to pause the video and
think about it so I'm assuming you've
had a go at it so let's think about how
many more of these boxes we need to fill
in in order to fill in all five of them
so we need to fill in one two and three
of the boxes in order to fill out all
five now we have five stars we have two
of the pink ones and we have three of
the blue ones so we can say that two
plus three the mystery number here is
three two plus three is equal to five
let's do a few more of these
so here I have four plus some mystery
number is equal to five and I filled out
four of the five boxes how many more do
I need to fill in in order to have five
things in order have all five boxes
filled out well we see very clearly here
that there is exactly one box that we
need to fill in or one box that we need
to add to the other four so we see that
4 plus 1 4 plus 1 is equal is equal to 5
now let's go the other way we have the
five boxes only one of them is filled in
how many more of these smiley faces do
we need to add in order to fill in all
the boxes or another way of thinking
about it we have one how many more do we
need to add to one to get to five and
like always encourage you to pause the
video and think about it on your own
well let's see we can add one we can add
two we can add three and four yellow
smiley faces so we could say one one we
have one white smiley face plus one two
three four yellow smiley faces is equal
to five and you see a pattern here let's
look at let's start at the beginning
three plus two is equal to five and two
plus three is equal to five when you hit
three filled in you did it two more to
get to five when you had two filled in
you did it three more to get to five
notice three plus two two plus three
same thing over here four plus one is
equal to five 1 plus 4 is equal to five